bella tutti ragazzi e benvenuti a
quest'uomo video sono quello che fai
video sul pil siamo al 2065 buon uso
ma chi se ne frega andrè con steve
ragazzi proviamo a fare le ultime due
con steve che sono abbastanza semplici
perfetto e una mera avendo fatto la
terza teoricamente ma c'è anche scritto
cosa devo fare
non faccio quello che dovrei fare ok
anche se come dovevo schiacciare neanche
quello che è dietro indietro indietro di
argenta zio avendo fatto la terza quindi
la più difficile le prime due dovrebbero
essere uno scherzo e che completiamo con
h demonio non lo completiamo stili
ripeto avendo fatto le prime due
dovrebbe essere abbastanza semplice loro
ok che a questo video ok alla faccia
esattamente quello che mi dici tu perchè
se no non sono muoio ok qua devo saltare
più in alto immagino zio credo
esatto perfetto
cosa faccio dove sto andare cosa succede
ok perfetto
ti prego la mia vittoria perché sto
sudando con un caimano non mi dà la vita
non c'è aiuto a chi è perfetto nel
tratto
la prima l'abbiamo fatta ragazzi la
prima l'abbiamo fatta mi manca solo una
abbiamo vinto steve attenzione adesso
non ci saranno più i tutorial ovviamente
quindi già già già se ce l'ho fatta a
malapena prima adesso sarà un casino e
private polgai diventato sto gioco ti
prego ma meno male che c'è la forza nel
collo tutto a posto fin qua tutto a
posto prima piattaforma signori che mi
sembra abbastanza fattibile ma perfetto
partner i perfetto questa non so se
chario ma ci provo
madonna che forza che cioè i muscoli del
collo sono incredibili il resto fa
schifo va bene ragazzi a posto il mio
collo in titanio è la mia migliore inter
scusatemi qualcuno mi spiega come mi si
è rotto il pogo prima perché non vorrei
ripetere lo stesso errore 17 di altri
non ho fatto nulla si è rotto da solo mi
si è rotto il pogo completamente da solo
quindi qual è il problema
ok fin qua tutto a posto non so neanche
dove sto andando bene
immagino che debba andare avanti di
sopra e non a destra ma vado di sopra e
mojo devo andare a destra ragazzi un
rigo io sabato di sopra noi lo conosco
già troppo bene sto gioco baba il vado a
destra e me ne fotto bene poco sono
ancora vivo sono ancora sono vivo sono
morta lo ragazzino da parte di sotto la
tuta a posto tutto a posto
posso fare anche subito non no problem
teoricamente non dovrei morire teorica
mendo ne sono completamente sicuro ma
secondo me con la parte così è anche più
facile perché è più facile guarda guarda
sono un bolide praticamente perfetto
allora teoricamente così dovrei riuscire
ad arrivare spero che non mi si rompa al
poco per troppo stress visto che
comunque mi fa anche da gambe speriamo
visto le premesse di prima non è il
massimo ok a posto tutto ok
aspetta aspetta aspetta aspetta o che ce
l'ho fatta e un livello che ci sto
mettendo due ore a fare ragazzi e
contate che il terzo l'ho finito questo
è il secondo se ho finito il terzo
ecco proprio lui senza le gambe senza
niente
e poi sono morto dopo però fa bene
allora ragazzi abbiamo fatto tutto
teoricamente ne ho ancora un sacco da
fare però stiamo finendo epic fail manca
veramente poco
andiamo con ed i ragazzi a fare un paio
di velina o se riusciamo allora ecco la
partenza da me il problema ragazzi che
steve aveva veramente solo tre livelli e
quindi quelli è normale che ce la faccia
bene ho paura che questi se non sono più
difficili
se ce n'è poi magari mi sbaglio
effettivamente non mi sbaglio però
secondo me si può andare 18 anche se uso
la piattaforma
proviamoci ragazzi non lo so perché è
tutto un intuizione sto maledetto giorno
e l'ora 1 ok 2 ok qua c'è uno stop
giustamente allo stop di vermi normale
patentato a posto allora fino adesso
tutto ok
[Musica]
perché dico che tutto che quando una
mera alleva il problema che scendere e
continuare a saltare gli ostacoli perché
il problema è proprio questo il tempismo
che io non ho ma ci provo lo stesso
perfetto ragazzi meraviglioso quanto
quando qua devo correre maggiori no ok
ok adesso devo correre problema che non
so se ci arrivo
ciao ciao cielo come ha fatto e passa
nuova per ragazzi l'avete non saprete
iscriverla sta cosa ma l'avete vista
tutti i vini a posto viva la magia
bene adesso che non ho capito che devo
fare qua devo stare attento ad andare
avanti mentre così si materializza non
ce l'ho fatta
non era di origine altamente meno male
meno male lavin traguardo zio da mentre
guarda ti prego bordatura posso anche
saltare qua e volendo madonna madonna ma
il giocatore soffre ma cos'è ma cosa ma
sono un fenomeno ma ragazzi aver fatto
tre livelli per adesso sono state volte
in cui ho fatti molti di meno e quindi
non è male per niente se lo citavano
canzoni livello all'inizio sei fermo
java ecco già indugia in questo partire
un casino figuriamoci il resto ci sono
bombe lo saltate posto ora i ragazzi
ancora uno e mi se mi ritengo
soddisfatto successo di oggi
volete un casco è gratis denise l'affare
ancora sto livello nel mio di oggi mi
sento soddisfatto e che ho fatto già
tanta roba che non è male ma soprattutto
perché era un po che non facciamo un
episodio è più smobile e quindi niente
male allora cadevo devo stare attento al
tempismo perché schivare sti cosi è
veramente più di fitch e di quello che
sembra
mannaggia il piccolo no ma non ce la
farò mai
non ce la farò mai
iolo ce l'ho fatta non ci voglio credere
aspetta però che un casino aspetta
aspetta aspetta aspetta spettacolo è
veramente non ce la farò mai più a
rifare questo pezzo che ho arrivo al
traguardo a te sono già arrivo ve lo
dico scrivo sono vivo
allora non so come farò rifare quel
pezzo sicuro perché facciamo fatto
stavolta io ho vissuto un miracolo
veramente ci voleva un tempismo pazze
comincia però mai più però proviamoci
dai allora salta adesso salta ricordati
di saltare bravissimo
non so dove dobbiamo arrivare però tu
salta nel dubbio salta sempre traguardi
vi prego cosa sono ma non è vero mi ha
fatto è una macchina mi ha portato il
cartello perché già scritto nuovo
insomma volendo sono andato fingo di
sotto mannaggia a te o ragazzo ritornato
qua ci ho messo due ore e adesso tu mi
spieghi
non voglio spiegazioni siamo a posto va
bene ultimo tentativo per vedere cosa
succede poi magari locomotiva nel
prossimo quattro vittorie sono già mega
contento è un teaser del prossimo video
ragazzi questo dia ping
ok dubito che lo finisco in una sola ma
troviamo niente da fare
o forse non capivo forse sono ancora
vivo no sono morto mannaggia
ti prego torna indietro ti prego ti
prego che ti costa che ti costa va dai
ragazzi questo era l'episodio è che
questi oggi arrivano le prossime bisogna
provare a fare sta roba
quindi sia piaciuto ragazzi fatemi
sapere nei commenti e lasciato bel mi
piace il video è piaciuto ovviamente se
non doversi cercare i file temi e noi
200 cv a ad un prossimo video per
ragazzi
[Musica]